introduction to soundscape Chris Yates
instructor and customer experience lead
guide dogs UK what is Microsoft
soundscape like colored hair blue eyes
Microsoft soundscape is an app that has
been developed in partnership with Guide
Dogs UK and is currently available for
iOS Microsoft soundscape provides
information about your surroundings
helping you to build a rich mental map
of the cities and places you visit and
it does this by using 3d audio by simply
connecting any stereo headset whether
that be Bluetooth or wired you'll
experience RIT's 3d audio as you
navigate the outdoor world Microsoft
soundscape is all about giving you
choice rather than dictate what you
should do the app allows you to make
your own decisions based on information
being provided putting you in control
you can use Microsoft soundscape in a
number of different ways whether that be
using it on a well-known route using it
with a friend or if you're feeling more
adventurous using it to discover new
places you've never visited before
during development our trials and
research showed that Microsoft
soundscape can help reduce levels of
stress and anxiety giving people with
sight loss more confidence when they're
out and about in an urban environment
Microsoft sales gate lighting up your
world through Sam the guide dogs logo
with a drawing of a man holding the
harness of a dog